president biden saying don't blame him
for the record high cost of gas which is
now 420. five a gallon the white house
even coming up with a cute little
hashtag
putin price hike like that's actually
going to make a difference
joe biden insisting the surge is all
putin's fault but take a look at this
prices they've been skyrocketing ever
since biden took office
after he promised to eliminate fossil
fuels
and while every day americans are
getting crushed at the pump the media
and the democrats they're just
dismissing concerns and pushing green
today the average gas price in america
hit an all-time record high of over four
dollars per gallon i'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon
because i drive a tesla perhaps if you
let the market work in this respect
people will feel pain they'll take a
second look at that ford f-450 gigantoid
truck they'll reconsider it tesla you'll
see hybrid innovation we should
ultimately learn our lesson here and
become energy independent and choose to
invest in clean domestic energy we have
to move to clean energy solutions clean
is in the end where we should be so that
we don't find ourselves in this position
again eralda rivera so joe biden has
said so many things about this first he
said that it was covid's fault and then
he said supply chain and then he said
there was nothing he could do about the
price of gas and then he said he was
doing everything to reduce the price of
gas and now he's saying i can't do
anything again about the price of gas
and it's going to go up
well i i personally don't think the
president of the united states has a big
role in setting the price of uh of
energy so why is he even trying to do it
because politicians can't resist the
temptation to say i can fix this or that
it's not my fault but i believe you have
to look at wall street you have to look
at the oil traders you have to look at
the guys who make money dealing it now
at these prices i'm going to go out and
drill oil everybody's going to go this
is you know what this is a fortune
overall this is a fortune to be made
here it's one thing when oil was the 30
dollars a barrel now it's going to go to
200.00
there's plenty of leeway and i think a
lot i go back to the permian basin which
i i know
midland odessa
you know
there's so much oil there there's so
many rigs with the last time i was there
uh buddy at the campus of the university
of texas
there are so many rigs that are just
sitting there they're not using them
because they the market didn't
demand it now the market is demanding it
now if they can make a buck it's all
about it's all about money
forget about politicians is it all about
money or is it about supply
it's all about the fact that this
administration has no strategy all they
do is react they have no plan they never
had a plan all he can do is blame russia
or blame trump or blame somebody else
the truth is that geraldo if these
prices have been going up since joe
biden came in we were energy independent
all was well the price of gas and we've
been over this a million times the price
of gas was affordable and then he comes
in and he's got this green energy uh uh
policy and even the guy who said you
shouldn't be driving that big black
truck and you should be reconsider a
tesla the guy who builds tesla says
drill baby drill
okay and in the end you know what we've
got or we've got it's not just it's not
just a keystone which is really the
pipeline that can bring the oil down
it's about the fact that everything in
this administration doesn't allow
for
drilling it's slow walking permits and
slow walking all of the the the policies
and the right-of-ways and the roads to
the lease and the supply and labor
shortages there was no planning that's
why we're in this mess and greg now
president called the saudis
saudis wouldn't pick up the phone
wouldn't take his call wow
there you go it's happened to you before
it happens a lot no one takes your call
when i try to get reservations for you
at the restaurant
i actually got in oh you did i did it
yes that's a mistake though applebee's
loves you uh anyway this does it
yes this exposes a flaw in most
left-wing ideas which is that they have
a goal which is a green 100 green
environment but they don't have a system
to get there so it leaves us in a
quandary when they cut when they remove
the solution which is drilling because
they have no real replacement so you end
up going after dictators oil instead of
our own and once again the hashtag
replaces real action they've probably
worked in that alliterative putin
hashtag for months but you get you get
the feeling that saki and from that that
montage this is an ideology of
punishment right they see the american
people as an amorphous blob with no real
life or feeling you know too bad they
don't have a cool job where you never
have to pump gas like gensake i you know
it's like i pump gas i pump my own gas
believe it or not everybody that doesn't
live in new jersey pumps around exactly
i love it in new jersey you don't have
to pump your own i enjoy that
i love the smell yeah
i love tipping the guy yeah all right so
can i say one thing about saudi arabia
yeah saudi arabia is a miserable country
i mean
that was necessary no no saudi arabia is
killing civilians in yemen
that
going back to what i said earlier about
my my moral uh failings and not uh
represent you know feeling sorry for the
people in aleppo when they were getting
bombed uh saudi arabia is bombing the
hell out of yemen they're killing
civilians right and left and the world
is silent on it because we want saudi
oil it's pathetic
we don't actually need saudi oil we can
just use american oil we can totally
de-link ourselves if we wanted to from
global oil prices and we could have
american prices i think we should just
ask
we ourselves should pump and we should
ask all of our allies to do it because
the global economy is going to need fuel
in order to keep going so we should do
everything we can here but let's get
everyone else to do it as well let's
talk about nuclear all that on the
hashtag thing the stupid thing about
that is twitter doesn't even use
hashtags anymore because what they they
remove the hashtag and they just like
pick up on keywords so you don't
actually need the hashtag
like you did and bring back our girls
this is the oh yeah this is the first
i've heard of this yes so you know so
hashtag no need for a hashtag that's
what we should be covering
that's the news you need to know but the
other thing i wanted to mention is okay
so they want you to all buy um
electric vehicles okay well electric
vehicles require a battery one of the
things you need to make the battery is
nickel where do we get nickel oh
oh russia
and where are the nickel mines being
held up oh america so you see the
pattern yeah that we're seeing here
hashtag pattern all right it is funny to
watch someone
in a very nice outfit sit back and just
say hey you know just go buy a tesla go
go buy an ep yeah like that like it's
that easy what about the lithium
batteries it's true from china exactly
all right i'll be at applebee's in about
an hour hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else